so our our our favorite
comedian pete davidson another guy who
let me down this year
my two big predictions for 2019 did not
come true
uh peter i thought he'd be dead and i
thought owen would be divorced by now
pete davidson bails on gig claims club
dissed him angry crowd turns on him
uh pete davidson is going to war with
comedy club owner because he refused
uh because the guy referred to kate
beckinsale and ariana grande while
introducing pete
however the crowd seemed to turn on pete
the snl star was supposed to perform
monday night
at vinnie brand's stress factory in
bridgeport connecticut
but he never made it on stage pete
claims vinnie disrespected me
and did something that i told him not to
do and i can't perform under those
circumstances
pete posted a video uh from his car
immediately after bailing on the gig
uh this is the hold on let me
this is this is the video
somebody does have the video tmz grabbed
the video this is this is what he posted
in his car
hey guys in connecticut i'm sorry that
we had to leave the show
before i got sure
why does why do all these junky loser
[ __ ] degenerates
all talk like bamar jarrah they're all
like mush mouth [ __ ]
guys in connecticut i'm sorry that we
had to leave the show before i got to go
on
uh the owner vinnie brand uh
disrespected me and uh did something
that i told them not to do
and uh i can't you know perform under
those circumstances however
everybody who got uh tickets to that
show i am doing a free show
for you guys we'll figure out where it's
gonna be in the next week
and uh you know we'll all get we'll get
it all sorted out sorry again
uh this is not your okay no no no no
pete that's not how it works vinnie
sold tickets for you to be there if you
don't perform
then vinnie has to return the money to
the people because you didn't perform
and then potentially
sue you right and then if you do a free
show to the people that went there
now you're [ __ ] vinnie brown that's
that's not how it
am i wrong mike you probably know more
about comedy am i wrong
that's not comedy that's business but i
get what i'm saying you know club owners
yeah no but even with the club owners
whatever you return the money and all
that right like all right
i could and this isn't just apply to
comedies to any
performing thing if you own a club
i agree to work at your club you pay me
whatever
i come and then i don't do the gig and
then i tell your audience i'm gonna go
do a free show
that's lawsuit territory i can't do that
no i'm not telling these people i'm
gonna take money out of your pocket
twice because now i'm also going to do a
show the night you're doing some other
show
right and everybody's going to come to
my show no that's a [ __ ] that's a
breach of contract
so this is this is this is vinnie
playing it
at the comedy club to the people
which was great by the way it's
something that i told my mom to do
and uh i can't you know perform under
those circumstances
so here's what i read real quick before
i play it so uh
vinnie when he was about to bring on
pete davidson's opener
or to that effect when his opener was
about to come on
he said uh something about all right we
have the open here but you know we gotta
put tp tapes on here in a second
there's some house rules joking around i
believe he said something to the effect
of like don't bring on
don't bring up kate or ariana that was
his joke yeah
and then then the opener came up after
the wasn't even a joke he was giving the
audience instructions
right uh while well so
really because i read it as it was he
was joking he was giving the audience
instructions his security guys
told vinnie brand you need to [ __ ]
make sure that really [ __ ] up vinnie
brand went up before the act real quick
was like hey guys just a couple
you know no photography whatever then
hey you know watch the
i mean he might have said it in a funny
way because that's vinnie brandt's
i thought it was in his nature to try to
go okay because
i've hosted shows before i know what
it's like to host a comedy show when
they give you rules
you try to find a funny way to tell
people the rules so that you're not
coming off like a buzzkill two minutes
before the [ __ ] headliner comes on
you can't go up and go
guys no photography no this no fun no
talking
know this know that if you're gonna go
get a drink be quiet about
because i'm gonna be like yo i wanna
watch funny i've done
gigs before like for bob kelly and other
people where they do have a couple
little ground rules
and you go out there and you're like you
make it funny you talk to him and he's
like hello you're not supposed to do
that you make a little joke so he might
have made a little offhand comment but
he was following their instructions yeah
kate broke up with him and he covers it
in this
show before you guys out where it's
gonna be in the next week
and uh you know we'll all get moved in
all sorts of i'm
sorry again uh this is not your fault
all right
get him up and let me know when you're
live and i'll do it right now
let's go hey this is a message
for all my uh patrons here at the show's
factory okay
don't date my daughter stuff if you're
on serious xm radio if you're a drunk
old six-year-old man stop having sex
with my daughter you hear me anthony
wait this is about pete davidson oh yeah
oh sorry
david guys i'm really sorry no
way in the world would i ever disrespect
any comedian and if you look at the
walls of the stretch factory
you will see bonafide superstars that
have worked for us
for years dlu and john wick obama no i
will say this about vinnie but vinnie
brand could be annoying but
people like working with him vinnie
brand is
very annoying vinnie brand is one of
those guys that constantly insists
himself up on stage for the big and
whatever but fine
but other than being annoying and trying
to get himself into everything and being
shameless
he does from by all accounts
take very good care of comedians that's
what i've heard like he's he's never
[ __ ] anybody on pay
he takes care even if you're not a
superstar comic
he takes care of comedians so that's a
yeah
chris rock the names go on and on and on
and pete davidson i didn't disrespect
you your security guy
told me to say what i said and if you've
got a bad security guy
you should have fired your goddamn
security guard you [ __ ] on
everybody here you know what it is to be
a comic
and then go don't talk about these
things and like you know you
said earlier when i think it was off
here where he was like but then you have
people like louis ck that
delve into their [ __ ] mistakes head
on
and they go wow look at me like you know
if you want people to forget you jerked
off in front of them talk about dead
kids
that was the line louis ck said yeah he
goes right out and just opens
and he takes a joke and people respect
him for it
this is don't talk about this don't talk
about that you're not a comic then pete
you're
a friend
[Applause]
it's one night when you were a young
comic you came you hung out at my club
in new brunswick
they treated you well when you were
having trouble last year
i texted you multiple times pete if you
need to talk anymore
i will say if you paid money to see this
this is a better show than actually
seeing people
of course this was i would have paid to
be here for this and plus you would have
gotten your money back
of course which is beautiful reach out i
tried so hard
and i went back in that room and i asked
you what you wanted
and you did not you were not
disrespected but you disrespected the
report which is something
impossible to do and then you start
getting reputations
getting better and better right and then
this struck an [ __ ] get the hair
across
because
[Applause]
i will agree somebody in the chat i
think was lisa said that like if you
paid to see pete davidson
you deserve to lose your money oh yeah
like the craziest [ __ ] woman here
that she's here somewhere
we're not dealing with that guy in this
day don't thank david
hey guys uh i couldn't do my show
because somebody said something that
hurt my feelings want to see my hillary
tattoo
dude i [ __ ] hate pete david he's very
hateable
he is probably right now the most hated
my most hated
my favorite thing about him too is like
if he posts on instagram or they write
an article about him or you go
anywhere read any comment section he is
so despised it makes me so happy